so obviously top gun Maverick has all
the stunts that we could ever dream for
and more were there any moments in this
film or across your career where you
thought
this could not end well here yeah many
times thank you for your time bro many
times many times have they like I don't
know it's just such a good idea but
we're in and let's go so
like oh we just listened it was very
intense and it was how do I prepare the
actors for this how do I prepare not
just the actors but the pilots
I had to teach the actors about Aviation
about editing I had to take the pilots
about how to edit and Cinema I had to
educate the studio on what kind of film
we're making because if things were
doing never been done before
and I'm thankful that
people were committed to doing it
because
you know I knew that I knew that at the
very least we would have something
special with it if everyone was
committed and on board